Roosevelt is the first person that
defined the term bully pulpit and what
he meant by it was that the president
has an unparalleled platform to educate
the country and to have moral fervor
delivered to the country so that the
people themselves will become
extraordinarily interested in certain
programs and push the Congress which in
his time was reluctant to act on the
problems of the industrialized push them
to take action so he really thought of
it as a pulpit in the sense that it was
a moral platform but bully and his time
didn't mean what we think of as bully
now it meant awesome or splendid or
great Roosevelt was the first person to
produce a room inside the White House
for the press he coincides with the age
of the reporter in the 19th century the
most important journalists were editors
and they'd often be editors of the
partisan magazines or partisan
newspapers if you were Republican you'd
only read the Republican Journal if
you're a Democrat only the Democratic
newspaper if you're a wig the wig
newspaper and the accounts would be
wholly different like Lincoln could go
and give a great speech in the
Republican Journal he's actually held up
they'd say by the shoulders of the
people as he left in the Democratic
account of that same speech they'd say
he fell on the floor he was not able to
get up he was hooted and and and just
sort of undone on his way out but by the
turn of the century you had national
newspapers coming into being more
objective you had national magazines and
reporters replaced editors as the most
important people of the time so
Roosevelt is coming into his own at the
time that's called the age of the
reporter and he recognizes that they are
the ones that are going to be reaching a
broader group of people not necessarily
his partisans but the country as a whole
and he needs them and they need him
you've got to hope somehow that
presidents understand that the bully
pulpit is still a tool that they possess
even though I think it's been diminished
over time as an instrument because when
Roosevelt gave a speech the entire
speech might be in the newspaper
headlines would tell about it the whole
country would be reading it even up to
the time of Franklin Roosevelt when he
gave his fireside chats on the radio 80%
of the audience would be listening to
his fireside chats Saul Bellow said you
could walk down the street
on a hot Chicago night and listen and
keep hearing his voice because you could
look inside everybody was listening up
till the time of the three television
networks in the 60s and the 70s and the
80s and up to Reagan you could give a
speech as a president it would be on the
air everybody's watching and then they
turn to regular programming
now you could watch your own cable
network if you want to you might hear
only an excerpt of the President's
speech you might hear the pundits
tearing it down before they even finish
the speech and our attention span is so
diminished that I don't know we can have
a sustained conversation about an issue
the way they could about monopolies or
corruption at the turn of the 20th
century but it's still a tool that a
president has to use especially when
things are so paralyzed in Washington
the only way you're going to get those
characters to move is public pressure to
say we've had enough we have to move
forward on some of these issues